[موسيقى]
سياحه الزفاف او وجهات حفلات الزفاف تعد
ظاهره سريعه النمو تشير لسياح الذين
يسافرون بغرض الزواج او الذهاب الى وجه
لحضور حفل زفاف صديق او قريب مصر تسعه الى
تدعيم الصناعه السياحه الزفاف التي دشنت
مؤخرا باقامه اول حفل زفاف هندي في شرم
الشيخ
حيث هو استقبل مطار شرم الشيخ الدولي قبل
ايام رحله كان علمتني اياها
337 راكبا من اجل حضور الحفل الذي اقيم
على مدار ثلاثه ايام متواصله لتكلفه
تراوحتنا بين ثلاثه الى اربعه ملايين
دولار هذا الحفل اللي ياتي في اطار الجهود
لترويج للمقصد السياحي المصري كم وجهه
لاقامه حفلات الزفاف حيث تقدم مصر الكثير
من التسهيلات لجذب سياحه الزفاف من خلال
الاسعار المنافسه بشكل كبير
ومراسم استقبال الرسميه تقديم الهدايا
للعروسين والحضور وتوفير برامج سياحيه
تناسب القادمه
يمكن ان تفيد المجتمع المحلي بشكل كبير
بما في ذلك الفنادق والبنيه التحتيه
والنقل والتجاره
وتمثل دعايه كبيره للنهايات
تلعب وسياحه الزفاف دورا حيويا للشركات
العامله في قطاع السفر والسياحه وسجل حجم
السوق نحو 21 مليار و 600 مليون دولار في
عام 2021 بحسب احدث بيانات لموقع
من المتوقع ان يصل حجمها الى حوالين 291
مليار دولار بحلول عام 2031 سياحه الزفاف
شهد النمو
75% في السنوات القليله الماضيه ونحو 25%
من حفلات الزفاف في العالم تجري خارج
المواطن الاصليه في ما يعرف بسياحه الزفاف
بالنسبه للازواج الامريكيين مثلا الارقام
تشير الى ان 40% من حفلاته زفافهم تتم في
وجهات خارجيه كمزدادت شعبيه رحلات الا
زفات السنوات الاخيره لانها توفر
للمسافرين فرصه المغامره الى وجهاتنا
متعدده والج بين الزفاف وشهر العسل في
مكان واحد وتعد ايطاليا اول مقصد اوروبي
يحتفل فيه العرسان بزفافهم خارجه بلدانهم
والثاني على الصعيد العالمي بعد منطقه
البحر الكاريبي تلهى فرنسا ثم اليونان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على الاستوديو لونا منظمه مصمم حفلات
الزفاف لؤي اهلا بك
طيب اولا سوق سياحه الزفاف
استثمار بالفعل الاستثمار عالمي ليس محل
الاستثمار عالمي صعبه
سياحه الزفاف خصوصا ب اربع سنوات الاخيره
تطورت بشكل كبير خصوصي بعد جاء يحبونه
تغير مفهوم حفل الزفاف حفل الزفاف ما عاد
مجرد حفل ساعتين ثلاثه صاروا العالم
بفضله يخلقه
تجربه
تمام تمام
[موسيقى]
هل هو شرط انه يكون البلد طبعه رومانسي
اهله وناسه رومانسيين ولا الاماكن هي الي
بتحكم
بساعد كثير بساعد كثير الصراحه اذا البلد
طباعه اهل البلد اول البلد بحجزاته
رومانسي بس هذا بيرجع على
الكابل يعني
للاختيار الكابل وين حابين يعملوا بدهم
شيء في يقع سعره وتاريخ
او مثلا حابين لا شيء همم
من حيث الاسعار والتسهيلات همم ما هي ابرز
الدول التي نجحت في استقطاب الاثرياء في
استقطاب منظمين الحفلات لي قامت حفلات
زفاف همم
همم الصراحه نمبر وان همم في عندك همم
اليونان اليونان
تمام جزر اليونان عندك ايطاليا كثير همم
في كل الجزر الاسيويه اللي هم نانسي شال
وكريم
مالديف تمام
هلا بيختلف كل شيء باتجاه باتجاه يورو
والمدى الايمان
الشرق الاوسط
باعداد كبيره امك
منطقه كانت بالنسبه لك اغرب وجهه حفل زفاف
اختاروا الكابل معين وتم بناء عليه دعوه
المعازيم والناس مكلفت يعني مش كل الناس
بتروح عليه
قبلت عملت ايفنت بالسيشل ااا سيشل كثير
حلوه همم
طبيعه بس يعني بلد ما فيها شيء غير طبيعي
همم بس يمكن كمل احلى الايفان تستعملهم
بحياتي من احلى الايفانسا
حفلات زفاف هل تقدم التسهيلات المناسبه
لكم
همم
تسهيلات بالاول كان في شويه صعوبه هلا عم
بتقدم كثير تسهيلات حتى عم بيقدموا
تسهيلات ممكن تعملي بامك تاريخيه مثلا
اماكن اثريه الامارات
[موسيقى]
طيب لؤي انا عروسه جديده وين في بتنصحني
كوجهها معينه اروح عليها مثلا الوجه
الامثل لسياحه الزفاف
[موسيقى]
الوجه الامثل وين قلبك مرتاح وجه الامثال
وين ال ال البلد او الفينيو اللي بتفوتي
عليه بتقولي هيدا مكان عرسي
شكرا
[ضحك]